he was Vince Keeler in Chicago Fire in
Aires one of the cody kids in Animal
Kingdom on TNT which is every Tuesday
night at 9:00 eastern time playing
opposite Ellen Barkin on that show he is
jQuery good to see you sir how are you I
just want to throw this on real clue now
that is an ancient old Jets hat well
it's a it's pretty it's just dirty
because I'm always throwing it on the
ground and like don't take it out on the
Hat Jake it's nothing you know nobody
says if I had to guess that looks like I
mean we're talking like Co tight arrow
Jets we're talking well you know the one
with 50 monophonic oh clecos like the
sack exchange of the lace 18 is it yeah
you're not that you're not you're a
youngster don't know her to that ninety
yeah okay so post sach Exchange
stock-exchange right around the Bruce
consulate Co tight I chair I'm this
online from like some dude and it was
like he had like a couple of them and I
was like can I can I have that one like
the really gross one you've got a used
jet about online
that's next-level thin if I got a pretty
mixed little so why why are you a jet
fan Jake why in the world I guess I mean
growing up I was so sick of everybody
talking about the Giants I just wanted
to where'd you grow up be different I
grew up in Montclair New Jersey
Montclair yeah about 10 minutes from
from Giants Stadium where how close is
that to where you grew up to Livingston
that's right down Australia living young
yeah of course yeah so what exit what
exit is there it's it's off the Parkway
it's one 126 I want to say why does it
every New Jersey ight honored yeah
that's what you are Jersey every New
Jersey I never flinches when asked what
exiting you from yeah that's technically
an insult I mean I'm really it's been 10
years since I've been back in New Jersey
so I hope I got that right well I mean
just you'll just know there's a jug
handle yeah you pump your own gas pump
load
or designer okay jersey is beautiful
okay people only know it for because
they fly in the Newark Airport and
they're like oh yeah they are tasty well
I mean that's right across from Staten
Island where there's like 250
petrochemical plants belching out smoke
stacks all the time that's where by the
way you know that's where Todd Todd
Bowles our current head coach those are
Elizabeth futures that's right Elizabeth
that's right yeah
love Todd Bowles you oh man I will see
we'll see you see what happens something
word a very quick I wish I love him I
love him it's that sad I know he sees
he's on the hot seat right now but I
don't look for yeah I mean yeah it's
like the what I mean I don't handle the
quarterback situation very well last
year I mean they should he ever handle
the quarterback situation well not since
Joe Montana no even ken O'Brien they
they passed on Dan Marino to draft him
do I really need to go down this whole
thing I will say are now but but last
year they should have absolutely sat
Ryan Fitzpatrick after he threw six
interceptions against the Kansas City
Chiefs I don't care if it was week
before or week whatever the hell and
they should have kicked the tires on
Bryce petty right then and there and
right now they're already thinking about
don't get me you got me started Jake
knows what he's like everybody's on the
Hackenberg train right now and it's like
we look I'm this it's a I get it's a
project
I love Hackenberg I I think you see he's
a great kid I just I don't I think we if
we had seen his potential we would have
seen it already and what I've got to put
this year I think I've got jQuery of
animal kingdom here on the Rich Eisen
show wouldn't you think if you are going
to see what's there uh-huh week one
throw them out there don't know right
I mean week one throw them out there why
we why would with all due respect to
Josh McCown Rizzo before Josh McCown I
love all these kind of I love Josh
McCown I love Josh McCown but I'm saying
I do not want to see him play at all
this season I really don't I say we
throw the kid in see what he can do I
know it's kind of a bad time to throw a
green quarterback into the situation but
but like why not yeah at buffalo that's
fun no and then and then taking on the
Raiders in okay in Oakland don't it's
their first home game hold on a minute
guess what guess what hold on it's not
only in Oakland where you know all sorts
of crazy stuff it always happens it's
the Raiders first home game with Derek
Carr back healthy
it's the Raiders first home game after
they find out that the team is leaving
all sorts of emotions yeah it's their
first home game with Marshawn coming out
of the tunnel good luck good luck what
do you think about Marshawn Lynch I love
it yeah I think he's going to be driven
to have that that mojo back is this a
fantasy question are you a fantasy
football yeah yeah I mean yeah what are
you thinking Marshawn Lynch what do you
think Bachman if you sitting there in
round 2 you take him round tooth pretty
early why wouldn't you take him with
that offensive line
why would look I would say on the
forehead workout videos on the beach
kind of had me thinking and I was
talking myself into it I don't want to
waste a second round pick on Marshawn
Lynch to be honest yeah there's lots of
ANB in my draft please I'm serious you
don't think marshawn's going to get the
ball inside the 5-yard line at least
once or twice you don't think marshawn's
gonna get 20 touches that's what's gonna
be the red zone guy I knew did you see
what he looks like in the preseason yeah
me too I don't really need to say that I
run for a lot of these star players but
for him I need to see it okay after
taking a year off
oh we're grocery shopping together and
the Gerry in the UH in the can try to go
in for you know we'll do it together
okay good we're doing that jQuery here
on the Rich Eisen show so you're from
Jersey and you're jet fan and you're
wearing your jet your jet hat right now
and I like Egypt if you take it off I
want to describe this for the radio on
it if you take your hat off you've got
like this blond mane that's flowing
right kind of going for like a like a
sutherland and Lost Boys well you do
have the last boy's parents yeah you do
have that Lost Boys Sutherland look I'm
trying to bring it back you know make it
cool yeah it gets up Kiefer in you yeah
yeah I got a little Kiefer me
if they're trying to do a remake or
something I'm your guy and then against
for the radio audience he is with the
top button down right now on the
button-down shirt and the hair and the
beard very Bryce Harper from the
all-star game look I think we've got the
split screen what do you think right
there Jake you think I'm so much more
attractive that's just mean I mean he's
as great as they come right there he
seems like a great guy yeah and then
that's the end of it like the was a palm
tree what he had something wrong yeah
like Miami theme cuz is that like a new
thing that they're doing the little
sleeves well yeah a let's just say
you're you've got a particularly a
physical seen an animal kingdom do your
own stunts Jake remember we try and do
all of our own stunts we try and do all
of our own stuff okay so let's say
you're you and Ellen Barkin are doing a
very stunt heavy scene that doesn't
happen too often I believe that okay
well I don't think that'll ever happen
show unfortunately well if your elbow is
ever in jeopardy you on one of those
sleeves okay and you could get it green
and white yeah I think we'll do one look
like the detail of our show like the
burning palm tree kind of thing going on
and think that's the animal kingdom over
the jets I would know I don't get you in
trouble here no because I love being a
Jets fan because I love how much people
like like to make fun of it it's just
that's that's the that's the whole thing
it's like just give me more I feel off
of it how old are you how old are you
Jake I'm 27 27 do you believe by the
time you're my age 48 you will see a
Jets Super Bowl championship in your
heart of hearts deep down in my heart of
hearts in your heart like yes so why I'm
not rare why not go host you have the
Stars dream big he's a patriot phantom
oh God
well at least you're not a Dolphins fan
I like that answer
you hate dolphin fans more than page a
listen pal I mean four before Belichick
left to be the H becaming HD of the nyj
for two days and went north and started
this whole business and the Jets took
Curtis Martin and all of us long before
that it was
gets dolphins it's generator and also
its the Jets often thing is just like
it's like who can who at the bottom of
the totem pole like who who's going to
do it you know like who's going to be
the one to it yeah yeah right now you
know that's what I like about the Jets
is we have nothing to lose and like I
tell people all the time it's like you
know you can't really it's like Ryan
Fitzpatrick on the brink of the playoffs
and then four and twelve you know it's
like we it's it's we're never going to
be that that you know the great
expectation team so it's like we can
only you know we can only kind of prove
people prove people wrong
jQuery has just come up with the Jets
slogan the 2017 New York Jets were
playing with house money that aspire you
over there it does not relate hey
everybody come on out we're playing with
house money
I like that Brandon cooks uh Phyllis
yeah that's pretty cool that's great
awesome that's really sweet excited oh
god you guys
Koni away David Harris it's just ended
us Burkett Harris I talked about the
David Harris I saw one time that whole
of doing Allen what do you say I mean I
I'm excited I mean it's it's nice to see
some young guys it's was nice to see
some young yes players for once
I like this our Darrius Stewart thing
going on I'm excited to see these young
receivers and see what they got look
this is this is one of those years where
it's just let's see what let's see what
kind of youth we got the 2017 New York
Jets let's see what we've got look
closely
God why not I am breaking news that
tweet yeah sure okay good
jQuery uses cutting edge where you want
to be involved in it you only go see
what we join in everybody I like it I
like it I'm excited
how's Animal Kingdom going for your
brother it's great I've been on hiatus
now for for a couple months and that's
been really nice to kind of just take a
break and and I went home for a bit when
hung out with my family they're all back
in New Jersey and it's but it's a good
it's an exciting season things are
starting to heat up like like I said we
were due
a lot of our own stunts we get to do
this like crazy I mean we get to go on
ATVs and and surf all the time and rob
banks and stuff it's just kind of like a
okay young kids like dream come true
like the stuff that they have us doing
it's just really exciting and sometimes
I got to pinch myself and I'm like I
can't believe this my is my job I get to
come into work and do this stuff every
day it's pretty pretty exciting and it's
on Tuesday at 9:00 Eastern 8:00 central
on on TNT check out yeah I got chick
things are going to really start to pick
up to nut we're nearing the end of the
season it starts to get really kind of
crazy so cook would guess so to speak
the exact fantastically thing jQuery jet
fan check him out on Animal Kingdom also
on Twitter at jQuery Tuesdays at 9:00
Eastern Time last one from jQuery 2017
Jets like me we're going on hiatus
which is the best one legit we got main
Jets were playing with house money Oh
relax
I only got like me we're going on ice
which one do you like - I like let's see
what we got I like let's see what we got
Twitter pull but that's either you huh
thanks for coming on come back you rich
thank you so much for bats on your eyes
a dream come true for me you guys what
the animal kingdom whatever talent
barking yeah and I'm talking to the
fellow Jets fans you got it what you got
it jQuery here on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you liked that
video be sure to download our app and
I'll be sure to help the NFL figure out
what it catches